- Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Priya Natarajan.
I'm the current director
of The Franke Program in Science
and the Humanities at Yale.
It is with deep sadness
that I would like to share
with you all the terrible news
of the passing of Richard Franke.
Rich was one of the founding
duo along with Barbara Franke,
who has kindly joined us today,
of this flagship
interdisciplinary program,
The Franke Program in Science
and the Humanities at Yale.
Today we mourn the passing
of a family member,
a kind, generous, and wise
elder who guided many of us.
To me personally, he was
an inveterate cheerleader,
keeping track of my
research work in science,
in astrophysics, sending
congratulatory notes
whenever he read about my work.
We would meet up over coffee,
and he would pepper me
with really hard science questions.
You know, he really was a space nerd
and had an incredibly curious mind
and was so widely read and knowledgeable
that it was just incredible how
he spanned all these worlds,
academia, the creative
arts, the business world,
politics, and philanthropy.
Both he and Barbara
remained strong supporters
of all our activities,
and I have very fond pre-pandemic memories
of all of us, the Franke family
along with the young
interdisciplinary scholars,
our undergrads, grads, and postdocs
getting together over dinner,
discussing bold new ideas
to explore and study.
He paid attention to all the talks,
asked incisive questions,
and felt very proud
of the young people whose
intellectual adventures
were not limited by academic silos
or disciplinary boundaries.
I'm at a loss for words.
Let me quote from a beautiful poem
by the Lebanese American
poet Khalil Gibran,
in which this, the book
from "The Prophet,"
in which it's a conversation
between the prophet and a human being.
"You would know the secret of death,
but how shall you find it
unless you seek it in the heart of life?
The owl whose night-bound
eyes are blind unto the day
cannot unveil the mystery of light.
If you would indeed behold
the spirit of death,
open your heart wide
unto the body of life,
for life and death are one,
even as the river and the sea are one."
So let's have a moment
of silence in his memory
to remember him as he
was, deeply empathetic
and a beautiful human being,
always smiling, energetic,
and brimming with
curiosity to forever learn.
Barbara, we mourn with you
and the rest of your family today,
and we wish you strength and courage
at this extremely difficult time.
You are both an inspiration to us all.
So let's have a moment of silence
before we start today's program.
Let's begin by recognizing
our benefactors,
Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
acknowledging the sad loss
of Mr. Franke last Friday.
Today's talk is one that we
have all been looking forward to
with great excitement,
and it is with great pride
and pleasure that I introduce our speaker,
one of our own Franke Fellows
who started this wonderful project,
cross-disciplinary project,
and despite many personal challenges,
health challenges has emerged victorious,
enthusiastic, and super-productive
in terms of his work.
So the talk today is by Diego Ellis Soto,
and the title is "Collective Pulse:
Uncovering the Hidden Lives of Animals
through Music Theory and
Artificial Intelligence."
I can tell you all
that you're in for a treat this afternoon.
First let me remind you that
we are recording this event,
and therefore all participants
will have to have their videos muted
for the duration of the talk.
Questions may be submitted at
any time in the Q&A feature.
So let me introduce our young
and brilliant scholar, Diego.
Diego is an Uruguayan biologist
studying how biodiversity across the world
responds to future, current
and future climatic conditions
in a rapidly warming world,
work, as you all know, is
extremely urgent and timely.
He tests ecological theory
using cutting-edge technologies,
animal GPS collar data, drone imagery,
citizen science data, satellite imagery,
statistical modeling for
applied conservation outcomes.
He's particularly
interested in understanding
how, why, when, and where species move
at local, regional, and global scales.
This is of course critical
in order to predict
the ecological consequences
of increased human activities
and changing climates on biodiversity.
While the bulk of his PhD work involved
sitting between a computer
screen and a desk chair coding,
Diego has performed
field work and research
on the ecology of giant tortoises
in Galapagos Islands
for the past nine years
and is passionate about
scientific communication
as well as his research work.
He joined Yale in 2018
and is currently a
fourth-year doctoral student
in the Department of Ecology
and Evolutionary Biology.
Besides being a Franke Fellow,
one that we are extremely proud of,
Diego is also an early career
Rufford conservation explorer,
a Yale Global Food Fellow,
a Law, Ethics & Animal Program Fellow
at the Yale Law School,
and an Environmental Humanities
student grant awardee.
He exemplifies the best of
what Rich Franke had in mind
for a truly interdisciplinary scholar
working at the cutting edge,
using cutting-edge technologies
to answer some really old,
profound, deep questions.
He obtained his undergraduate education
in environmental sciences
from the University of Trier
and his graduate studies
in biological sciences
at the University of Konstanz.
Shortly afterward, he worked
at the Max Planck Institute
for Animal Behavior,
leveraging large amounts
of biological data
for hundreds of species across the world.
During this time, this is the
most enviable part of his CV,
he lived in the Galapagos
Islands for over a year,
working with the giant tortoises
and spent several months
in the Ecuadorian Amazon
working with poison frogs.
He worked as a DJ throughout
his time in Germany
and performs music at the interface
of natural sounds and electronic music.
I mean, I think his resume
is just impossibly filled
with sort of these talented things
that he has productively engaged in.
I don't know how he has
time to do all of this
given how young he is, but there you go.
He's also very passionate
about scientific communication,
and of course his work, which
as you will see in a moment,
just is at the frontier.
It has been featured in
dozens of news outlets
including "BBC Nature"
documentaries, in "New York Times,"
Spanish newspapers, "ABC News,"
"Yahoo News," and so on and so forth.
In addition, his most recent work research
is the impacts of altered human mobility
during COVID-19 pandemic on
wildlife across the world
and has been endorsed
by the United Nations.
So COVID, as you all know,
the global pandemic not
only impacted us humans,
but the entire natural world.
It was traumatic for the
entire natural world.
Diego aspires to bring the humanities
and the natural sciences together,
both at work and in his spare time.
He performs in electronic music
festivals across the globe,
and he's increasingly interested
in combining electronic
music with soundscape ecology
using open-source technology.
We are also delighted today
to have Matthew Suttor,
professor in the practice of sound design
at Yale School of Drama,
who will be joining Diego
today in his presentation.
Professor Suttor has been a
leading part of this project
alongside Diego since the beginning.
We're particularly grateful
for his continued support
through personally
difficult times for Diego.
New Zealand-born composer Matthew Suttor
has taught at Yale University since 1999,
first in the Department of Music
and since 2002 at the David
Geffen School of Drama.
He's also affiliate faculty
at the Center for Collaborative
Arts and Media at Yale.
Often combining music
technology with acoustic forces,
Matthew has composed operas,
dance works, and music
for all kinds of theatrical productions,
chamber music, and sacred
sound installations,
scores for television, and so on.
His work in opera and dance
includes "Don Juan in Prague"
in collaboration with the
director David Chambers
for the Bard SummerScape Festival,
which was revised for the
Mozart Prague Festival,
the Guggenheim Works and Process series,
and the BAM Next Wave Festival.
He composed Zoomslide's
television series "Real Pasifik"
and Anna Marbrook's documentary
feature film "Loimata."
He has been involved with
Yale Rep Theatre productions
that include "The Intelligent
Design of Jenny Chow,"
"All's Well That Ends
Well," "The Winter's Tale,"
"Arcadia," and "An Enemy of the People."
He's extremely distinguished,
a Fulbright Scholar,
and he received a doctorate in composition
from Columbia University.
I could spend the entire hour telling you
about the wonderful accomplishments
of our two scholars today,
but without further ado,
let me turn it over to Diego.
Diego and Matthew, thank you so much
for speaking to us today
and sharing your ideas.
- Thank you so much, Priya,
for this kind introduction.
Thank you, Ms. Franke, for letting us
dream big with the support.
So none of this would have been possible
without this initial support
from the Franke project,
and I hope to show how an
initial support towards students
can snowball into a larger project
that is "Collective Pulse" now.
So thank you for believing in us.
Today I'm very excited to
present that joint work.
I'm extremely flattered
to be giving this talk.
It's a professional highlight for me.
Thank you for the opportunity.
This is a large team effort in
a truly collaborative manner,
as hopefully you will see
in the last acknowledgement
of my slide, involving people on farms,
local hospitals, engineers,
music, musicians,
composers, ecologists, conservationists.
It's been truly a pleasure and a privilege
to be able to work with every
single one of these people
and particularly Matthew for
the patience, the mentorship,
and the expertise and just the creativity
to dream big and take this forward.
Today we'll be talking about new ways
of exploring the natural world
and looking at the hidden lives of animals
through a bird's-eye view, literally,
using new emergent
technologies that let us
capture the voyages of animals
and how they sound like
and how they look like and
the danger of what happens
if we lose this incredible beauty
in the natural world by human activities.
And I would like to introduce
the main characters of today's band.
We have flying pigeons on a piano.
We have homing pigeons
on a different piano.
We have stickleback fish on the drums.
And we have eight termites
that decided to make a mixture
of electronic music and classic guitar.
So the beauty of the natural
world knows no limit.
Many of us probably have
seen these incredibly flocks
of tens of thousands of birds
flying at once in unison.
And this looks incredibly harmonic,
and people have wondered for a long time,
how do these rules go together?
Do they have telepathy?
How do tens of thousands of
animals organize in unison?
And to many people like Matthew,
this probably looks like music,
and he will expand a
little bit more on this.
At the same time, how I started,
this is me on the left next to my brother.
I'm the one with the
glasses as a five-year-old.
I guess I've always liked
animals and biology.
And on the right side, I
sort of always liked music.
I'm the little one watching
my brother jealously
playing the flute while my dad
is looking at musical sheets.
But I always played my cards right.
This was outside an airport
where we asked adults
for money to then buy candy
and some dinosaur toys.
So I think I've always
had a passion for music,
getting a lot of different people together
to get the most out of a
project as a collective
and inspiration of the natural world.
I actually started in the humanities.
I started as a journalist and then quit
and went to Germany to study biology.
Little did I know that
it would change my life.
Fast-forward 25 years, I
now study animal migrations,
particularly across the
world, and how they move
and how biodiversity is
moving under global warming.
Here we can see a picture of the globe
where every single pink
line is a individual animal
tracked with a little GPS collar
that allows us to monitor
the voyages of these animals.
And we can see almost that animals
are almost like veins or
pulses across the world.
As they are following snowmelt
in the Northern Hemisphere,
they're going up, and as snow comes back,
animals are going down into
the Southern Hemisphere,
almost like a collective
pulse through the planet.
And this is something that
I've been investigating
in my PhD for a very long time.
And in my laboratory at Yale
University led by Walter Jetz,
we're also very interested
in creating tools
that allow the public to
visualize these voyages of animals
and represent the hidden lives of animals,
bringing them closer to the
public, such as Animal Lives.
But also during the last years,
I've been focusing more
on music production
using a variety of different softwares.
On my PhD, I use a lot of
different technological advances
to improve the way that we can monitor
and document biodiversity
and how it's changing.
For example, on the right side,
we have over 900 satellites
measuring environmental
conditions 24 hours a day
that allows to measure
the pulse of the planet
in terms of vegetation
greenness, as seen on the left.
And this is incredibly important
and increasingly important
because we're currently in
the sixth mass extinction,
and this is a human man-made catastrophe
with human activities driving
several species to extinction.
And what's even worse
is there's many species
we don't even know about,
and we are losing not just
important ecosystem services
but also the incredible beauty of nature,
their sounds, the way they look like,
and it's really important to document this
and better understand
the change through time.
This is, for example, an
article that highlights
some scientific communication
of my research lab,
where through maps we're able to visualize
biodiversity closer to humans.
And actually because
of this Franke project,
I've started to think
maps are a really, really
incredible way of communicating narratives
and scientific stories to humans.
But music can be the same, too.
And this is something that we
are increasingly able to do.
We can document human
activities through time,
and we're able to understand
the impacts of biology on these changes.
For example, we can see how urbanization
and human activities
are changing ecosystems
but also what ecosystems sound like.
And by here, I wanna say
that this is by no way
something that we have invented here.
There has been many people
that have pioneered this work,
and I wanna highlight two of them,
namely Benjamin Patterson,
who was an incredible
artist and was composed,
was employed as a classic bassist,
but he was denied employment
because of his race,
and he recently died 2016.
But to my knowledge,
he was the first person
exploring how to make music with ants.
And what Mr. Patterson
did, he put a music sheet
on the ground and tossed ants on it
and followed their movements
by drawing on a pen.
And here you can see Mr. Patterson
trying to make musical
sheet out of data of ants.
And he later has mentioned
that while this is not music
or musical, it's a new
method of making music.
I also want to acknowledge work
by Bernie Krause, a soundscape ecologist,
and he created the soundtrack
of "Apocalypse Now."
And on the left, we can see Mr. Krause
deploying some sensors
to look, some microphones
to look at habitat change in ecosystems.
And on the right, we can see Mr. Krause
with one of the first Moog synthesizers
such as Matthew has in
the back to make music.
And Mr. Krause also said,
"A picture is worth a thousand words,
but a soundscape is worth
a thousand pictures."
And this is actually incredibly important.
And Mr. Krause has recently
wrote an incredible book
called "The Great Animal Opera"
with interesting insights
as of how humans learned how to dance
based on the natural world,
and his concept of the animal opera
was covered by the Sydney Biennale,
and what you can see,
there are sound waves
of the natural world
on the orchestra house
in the background.
So there's increasingly appreciation
also in the larger public around the work
of documenting soundscapes
and documenting biodiversity.
And this is incredibly
important also as a biologist,
wearing my global change biology hat,
because Mr. Krause recording from the '60s
allows to document not just how sounds
and ecosystems has changed,
but whether species are still there or not
and why this might be and how fragile
soundscapes might be
due to human activities.
So it's an incredibly powerful tool
of scientific communication
but also to understand the natural world
from a scientific perspective.
And what is new here in our project
is that we are trying
to document and leverage
these new, incredible technologies
that are available to us
as scientists, namely
animal tracking technologies
that let us put up
satellite tech on an animal
and follow it its entire lifetime,
computer vision that allow us
to track hundreds of
animals simultaneously,
as we can see in the
middle, termites or fish,
up to the right side where
we have smartphone apps
that have machine learning algorithms
that allow us to identify any
bird calling in the real time.
You're going to see a
chickadee, I think, arrive
and being recognized almost
instantly by these algorithms.
So we're able to leverage
this incredibly amount
of biodiversity data for
conservation purposes, ecology,
but also to bring this
incredibly fragility
of the natural world and incredible beauty
closer to the public.
And we are not alone here.
As I said, there's many people
have thought deeply about this.
And Aristotle mentioned
even in his book "De Anima"
written 2,000 years ago
that every kind of animal
should be studied and revealed
as it has something incredibly beautiful
in the natural world.
Well think, fast-forward 2,000 years,
now we have really good, powerful AI
that allows us to track a
lot of different objects,
humans, and species in incredible detail,
and we're able to leverage this for tech,
for conservation, and for good.
As shown here in 2015 by Rosenthal et al.,
this is a Facebook social network of fish.
Here we can see a number of fish,
and the graphs and the nodes between them
is the relationship that
each of these fish has
to their neighbor and
their local interactions.
So we can not just
uncover the hidden lives
of single animals, but
what's even more fascinating
is their collective behavior.
And incredibly research
in collective behavior
has shown that actually
very simple rules in nature
determine very complex patterns.
As seen here, there's three
different collective states
that animals could be in,
and these are largely determined by,
animals don't wanna be
too far away in groups.
They don't wanna be too close together,
and they wanna move at a similar speed.
And we could think of these
three different states
as being almost universal in nature.
Swarming can occur in
mosquitoes, it can occur in fish.
Polarization, when
there's almost a harmonic,
very directional movement.
It's almost like a V formation in fish
or a V formation in flying fish.
And milling can occur in fish or in,
if any of you ever wants
to Google reindeer cyclone,
it's when reindeers move in a circle,
very fun video to watch.
But what on earth has this to do
with music theory and music?
Well, this is when I had the
pleasure of meeting Matthew
right before the COVID-19 pandemic,
and we started talking about these things,
and it has been an absolute pleasure
and privilege to work with him.
And I would like to give Matthew the work
to explain a little bit more.
- Thank you, Diego, and
good afternoon, everybody.
So as Diego was just explaining,
the basic rules of
collective animal behavior,
and this is a composer
explaining to scientists,
which I acknowledge, is
that animals want to move
in a common average direction,
common average speed,
and common average
distance from each other.
Those are the rules of harmony.
That's how I teach students how to compose
a chorale in the style of Bach.
They're the rules that Palestrina used,
and they're still the same rules
that we use to write pop songs.
So if I talk a little bit
about the ideas behind
it, so when I look at,
say, the murmuration of starlings,
you saw that, a video that
Diego showed earlier on,
I look at that, and I think,
"That looks like music,"
but it's not a trivial thing to work out
how to take that
three-dimensional behavior,
even if you have really
elaborate exact tracking data,
and then map that onto musical parameters.
So by musical parameters,
I mean pitch, rhythm,
duration, articulation, phrasing,
timbre, tone color, et cetera.
So the first place or the obvious place
that we wanted to explore is
that if we have, for example,
XY coordinates on a Cartesian plane
tracking individual animals,
well, then we could map
that to, say, pitch.
And in music theory, we
talk about pitch space,
and in this case, we're looking
at what's called a Tonnetz,
which is 19th century music
theory, this is not new.
And you can see that moving left to right,
we've got, on the horizontal,
we have perfect fifths.
And then on the diagonal,
we have various kinds of
thirds, major and minor thirds.
And if you look at the
triangulation in the middle,
C, E flat, G, that's a C minor triad.
And then if you flip underneath,
C, G, E, that's a C major triad.
So there's a way in which you
can theoretically navigate
around a pitch space and
map coordinates to it.
We're even, started to look
at more complex shapes.
Here we've got a Tonnetz
in the shape of a torus,
which are mathematical friends,
and sisters actually,
still two-dimensional.
I wanted to call it three-dimensional
and was (laughs) quickly disused of that.
And so as I mentioned,
this is not a trivial thing to work out.
Well, how do you make
music from this data?
So we've had some breakthroughs recently
that I'd like to share,
just to give you a taste
of where we are heading.
So here I have the beginnings of,
taking the data that we have
for a group of 10 homing pigeons.
And so the data
is around 150,000 lines,
which includes XY coordinates
and also other information to work out
whether they're milling,
swarming, or they're polarized.
And so simply what I've
done is we've taken that,
the Cartesian coordinates,
and the breakthrough,
which actually came, well,
how do we visualize this?
And through thinking through
visualizing it for you,
we mapped the Cartesian
coordinates to polar coordinates.
And then lo and behold, we found a way
of mapping that to pitch space.
So what I'm gonna play
here, which is actually run,
is gonna run in real time,
it's not a recording,
is taking the data of XY coordinates,
turning them to polar coordinates,
and then mapping that to a pitch space,
and then sending that to another program,
which is gonna play back chorale samples.
So now we're in theory
have a choir of 10 pigeons,
and it, to me, it sounds like music,
but that may be debatable,
but it's a first step.
Here we go.
(inspiring choral music)
So that's the beginning of something that,
at least from a
compositional point of view,
I really do feel that we've
got something to work with.
So just to show you
briefly what it looks like
in terms of actual music,
so what we were playing then
was recorded in real time,
and there we have pigeons,
homing pigeons producing chords
that if I were to look at this,
I would say, "This is music."
And so I'm pretty excited
about the potential for this.
The next step, of course,
would be to take this
and then map the movement
onto a surround sound system,
so a kind of cinematic experience.
It might even extend as far as, say,
a virtual reality experience
where you could be a pigeon
in the flock of pigeons while listening
to the realization of this.
So this, we're really excited for this,
and something that was an
unexpected thing for me
is to look at, say, these
recordings of environments
that Diego's gonna be getting into
and making musical realizations of those.
So it's not just the flocking
or the schooling data,
but actually taking
environmental recordings
and then mapping that onto musical spaces,
so the sonification and
visualization of data,
which is something that
I'm really interested in
as a way of showing people
what is happening in the environment.
So it's one thing to sort of say,
you know, "Here's what's going on"
in terms of some kind
of abstract description.
It's another thing to
express it through art.
So that's part of the project,
and I'm really excited
to be working with Diego,
and I will hand it back to him, thank you.
- Thank thank you, Matthew.
We are not the first people
to talk about data sonifications.
NASA has been working on
this for quite some time.
Here we can see what
the galaxy sounds like.
(calm music)
Different colors are different pitches.
(chimes tinkling)
But I do believe that one
of the major advantages
and progresses of this project
is that we are applying
both musical theory and biological theory,
for example, as the Tonnetz
that Matthew has mentioned.
We are also adding, we've performed-
(jarring music)
Apologies, we're also
exploring different ways
of playing with chord
progressions and feelings.
For example, as some of
these collective states
in which animals can be such as swarming
or whether they are transitioning
from one state to another,
these are somewhat more
chaotic, or we can, for example,
add different chord progressions
to them to evoke emotions
as animals change from
a more chaotic system,
such as swarming, to a polarized state.
And in addition, we are
exploring new ways of,
such as the, we call it the pigeon reader,
what Matthew just showed you,
almost of creating new
synthetic synthesizer
or instruments that artists could use.
And the interesting part of this
is that this would represent
a direct connection of
nature with an artist.
So it actually really physically matters
where the artist is in space
and how the output of some of
this music might sound like.
And I'm going to jump a little bit
into some variables of interest
that we've been interested as biologists,
and I will showcase you four
different examples of music
that was generated by different animals
and how this has a little bit evolved
in complexity through time
as we've learned so
much from this project.
If we have a group of fish, for example,
we could look at a single fish.
We could look at how fast are you going,
how fast is this fish accelerating,
what's the distance between its next fish.
We could also look at
the collective and say,
what's the average
speed of the collective,
where's the collective average position,
what's the degree of alignment
among this fish called polarization,
how much are they moving around
their own axis, rotation,
is this a collective state that is stable,
such as polarized, or are
they trying to transition.
And I'm going to try to showcase
some of these parameters
we've been playing around
with with some pigeons.
In this example, we split
our pigeon group into three,
and these three groups of pigeons
represented three different
notes on a keyboard,
and it's going to sound very clunky.
(chaotic music)
- [Priya] Diego, we are
losing the sound somehow.
Could you turn it up?
(discordant music)
- Is this better?
- [Priya] Yes.
- So this is a very chaotic, clunky sound
as displayed in the
art on the bottom left.
And I'm excited to say
that we currently have
an art exhibit opening that's
gonna display all this art,
and we will show you a little
bit later a glimpse of it.
Our next artists on the ensemble
today are stickleback fish,
and this is an image of
these fish in a fish tank.
And I showed this to
an artist at Tsai CITY,
and he was surprised by
how beautiful this was.
And I said, "It was made
by the animals themselves.
This is their reality.
This was their experience in
couple hours in a fish tank."
So we are communicating
with different artists
and sculptors of exploring new ways
of representing the natural world
through the animal lives themselves.
And this is, we have
applied the same principle.
We have a group of I think it
was 10 fish in a fish tank.
We have split this into groups of three.
So if you're closer to others,
you will become one key on a pitch space,
as Matthew was explaining,
and as the fish moves,
the different keys will change.
(discordant music)
(somber music)
And it's very interesting
because you can even listen
that these animals are
in a different medium.
Fish can turn around
because they're in water.
A pigeon can't just make a
full stop and then turn around.
So we can even listen to different mediums
in which these animals live
and experience the world.
These are the actual homing pigeon
that Matthew was showing you.
These were tracked with GPS
collars, and every single one,
and they're part actually
of a seminal paper
that discovered leadership in pigeons,
who's leading a flock of pigeons.
So we're actually using
cutting-edge scientific data
for this data certification.
This is a previous version
of Matthew's pigeon reader,
and on the top right, we can see the art.
This is the actual tracks
and the actual data,
so the raw Excel sheet
plotted on a landscape.
It looks like a artist just made a splash,
and every single color is
a different individual.
And here we're going to
see Matthew performing
and practicing live at
our opening at Tsai CITY
earlier this week.
(inspiring choral music)
It was so much fun.
And here we have my personal favorites.
These are eight termites on a Petri dish.
And here I wanna highlight and showcase
how our artificial intelligence
computer algorithm works,
namely, it's able to track
every single termite,
and each different termite is tracked
in its position and its time
and it's unique identity.
And what we get out of
this is the raw data
of a time, a frame, a position in x space,
a position of y space, and the identity.
And this is the raw building block
for a lot of these musical parameters
and collective behavior
parameters that we're creating.
This means that we can make this
for almost any single animal now on.
and we have the code, and we
are planning to make the code
fully available in public in GitHub.
We want everyone to be able to
use this and claim by no way
that we should be the
only ones doing this.
And in this piece made by
eight different termites,
we have an individual termite
on I think it was on a guitar, yes.
And then we have three
different parameters,
collective behavior parameters of termites
translated into music and
three different pianos.
So the only thing I did as a human being
was assign different instruments
to different parameters of these ants.
(lively music)
And besides just computer
vision, artificial intelligence,
I also mentioned these
have incredible advantage
in sound recognition.
And for this we've put
little birds by microphones
and computers, Raspberry Pis and AudioMoth
with $9 microphones from Amazon,
the cheapest I could find,
and we put them on the
Yale Farm for a month,
and we're planning on keeping them up
a little bit longer to
document bird migration.
And what was incredible is
that we detected 60 species
at the farm in this four-week experiment
and documented over 20,000 observations.
And if you're wondering
who was the loudest
and most common bird, you guessed right.
It was the blue jay, very loud
bird, very beautiful bird.
And what this AI also allows us to do
is it allows us to document the species
but also a confidence
of how certain the AI is
that it has documented a certain species.
So beyond musical interest,
this is incredibly exciting
for bird biodiversity
because we can document
biodiversity through time
24 hours a day for under $200.
So this could be and is
currently a game changer
in biodiversity research.
Especially thinking and
communicating about this work
with artists, musicians,
activists, it has changed the way
that I see a little bit my own science,
because if we can use all these tools
to educate the next
generation of scientists,
policymakers, and musicians, children,
we could empower them
to collect and sample
and listen to their neighborhoods,
learn computer programming on the way,
which is a really important skill,
learn about the natural world,
become stewards of their environment,
have a lot of fun doing
it, spend time outside,
which has been really
important during COVID,
and make music and art out of it.
So this is called SHTEAM.
So it's STEM, humanities and art.
And I'm thrilled that Tsai
CITY gave us the opportunity
to open an art display this week
in this incredible building.
And it's open until Friday morning,
so please check it out
if you have the time.
The building actually
looks like a fish tank
and a bird nest.
And we opened this award, and this was,
as a basic scientist,
this was my imagination
of what this art exhibit
could've looked like,
I'd never done this,
and I think we actually came quite close.
So I invite you to take a
collective plunge with me here.
This is the building.
Here we have someone exploring
the birds by microphone,
trying to play a bird sound and
see if it can be documented.
To the right side, we have a little poster
describing what we found at the farm,
who the loudest singer was,
who ate the farm compost,
scientific communication.
In the back, we have the music
generated by our eight termite artists.
In addition, as I mentioned,
the next generation
is what matters the most
because they will follow
up with this work.
And I'm very proud to say that we launched
an art exhibit contest
throughout New Haven
asking children of any
age to paint any wildlife
in Connecticut, and we made flyers
both in English and Spanish,
and we were overwhelmed by the talent,
the incredible imagination of the artists.
And here are the winners.
We have Lillian Delgado who documented
every single owl in Connecticut.
We have Leslie Pawlak, a second grader,
documenting birds and mammals.
And we have Alina Zhang
making a 3D chicken,
and she sent me several
pictures of the process,
which was just mind-blowing.
And here we have all the other artists.
And I have to say that because
we made this advertisement
in Spanish, we got 40% of emails
and submissions that were in Spanish.
And the robin was the
most common animal drawn.
And as a biodiversity scientist,
it's interesting that birds and mammals
were the most frequent ones
being painted by children.
And I'm trying to think
about a more 10,000-foot view
about this whole concept.
I love the idea of generating
new ways of visualizing
the natural world and sonifying it
and bringing it back into the
hands of the human artists
And this is, for example,
how our little microphones
(screechy music)
in real time can be put into the hands
of artists such as Matthew.
And I have to say that last
week was the first time ever
that we practiced music because
of the COVID-19 pandemic.
Most of this work has been done on Zoom,
and it was an absolute
pleasure to just brainstorm
and code and make music together.
We're incredibly lucky to
have been supported by artists
and cancer survivors of
Yale Smilow Hospital.
These are origami cranes made
by patients in the hospital,
and there's a Japanese tradition
that if there's a thousand origami cranes,
all your dreams will become true,
and you will have good health.
And I'm very grateful
that these incredible
art pieces were lent to us.
You see them at the Smilow Hospital.
And I love the fact that
they're in pride colors.
And we also got incredibly
Smilow rocks that just,
these are the moments that remind me
that before a scientist,
I'm also human being,
and just reading these
just springs my curiosity
into a million pieces, and
I'm going to read some of them
because they're so powerful.
"Dance to your own music.
The birds sing even when it rains.
The song of the earth
writes the music of my soul.
Listen closely, even the trees
exhale their own love songs.
Sing the song you were born to sing.
Be still and listen.
The earth is singing."
And these moments are,
besides my being a scientist,
these moments just bring me back
and make me think so much bigger
than my scientific research
and what the impact
could be of this project,
also to bring joy to people
and promote education
and equity in a just way.
We also were very lucky
to have three art pieces
by local artists and scientists
that are on display in the art gallery.
And these are just some of the
images, incredible building.
If you have the chance, please go.
And this is Matthew and me performing live
for the first time ever with
the pigeon Gregorian choir.
Here's a colleague, as a collective pulse,
trying to change the stream of music,
and that's totally fine.
And this is another fact of so
many things that I've learned
by working with humanities artists,
I invited some of my
friends who were dancers
to participate, and I said,
"If you come, you can dance."
So they did, and so I did.
And this just sprung my
creativity to gave me new ideas
and make me a better scientist.
What if we map all these
things into dancers?
The last piece of music I will play today
is a sneak peek into a
electronic music production
made by the termites where, again,
the only parameters that
I decided as a human
were the instruments they play.
And here we have four
different colors of ants,
which just means that I've
looked into four different
patterns of the entire group at once
and mapped them into
different music space.
(dramatic music)
(lively music)
(harmonious music)
And to bring this back together,
what I've learned
through this art exhibit,
by collaborating with scientists, artists,
musicians, having an
incredible team behind us,
everything I've shown today
is a collective effort,
and the most important people are the ones
that I will show in my last slide,
but every single city can probably do
some of what we've shown today.
Every city has a school, and
we could teach SHTEAM there.
Every city has a little
farm or a green space
or a vacant lot or an urban garden
where we could document
biodiversity through food justice
and make music out of a farm.
I'm excited to make Yale Farm music
with chicken being hi-hat,
shovels being snares,
and birds being the melody.
A lot of places have
hospitals or community centers
or universities, so I see
this whole presentation
of "Collective Pulse" that
we've demonstrated today
as a very larger envelope and umbrella
of bringing the natural world, technology,
art, and humanity closer together,
just like the general
purpose of the Franke Program
as envisioned by Mr. and Mrs. Franke.
And you might be asking what's next.
I've learned a lot about working
with the humanities in this project.
It's sprung my creativity, my curiosity.
I love the fact that a lot
of times artists sit back
and let people be and explore,
which is little bit different
than how we work in the sciences.
I learned about communication,
being very clear,
interdisciplinary work,
non-verbal communication,
data visualization, emotion,
the subjectivity of interpretation,
the hard questions artists ask,
and that small grants make us dream big.
I've also learned from my dancing friends
that this is something I wanna do later.
Maybe each one of these
dancers is a collective,
and what if we try to reconstruct
through their movement
the music that they were singing to?
Is that possible?
There's gonna be so much variation,
and each time they
dance will be so unique.
Maybe we can recreate this.
I have no idea, but I'm
excited to find out.
I'm excited to explore more the sounds
of entire ecosystems and how
they have changed through time.
How do the ecosystems from
1960 sounded of Mr. Krause
versus how they sound now in 2022?
And artificial intelligence
allows us to split sounds
into the natural sounds and human sounds,
for example, with great ease.
So I'm very excited about this.
We could make music
about every national park
in the United States.
What does the underwater sound?
Also something we'll be tackling.
Exploring more musical chord progression
with Matthew's mentorship.
Working more with the local
community in New Haven,
which is, the biggest excitement
of this entire work was opening my email
and seeing artwork from
kids, to be honest.
That has been the highlight
of this project to me personally.
And stay tuned because more is coming.
We're just getting started.
We have another opening on Saturday.
We have a Climate Bauhaus
at the Center for Collaborative
Arts and Media, please come.
And this is actually
art made by Dana Karwas,
but this is made out of termite data.
It's gonna be a large print,
so please check it out.
And this is the large team
that I was talking about
that has made everything happen.
And please take a second to look
at the interdisciplinary
nature of these people.
We've got anything from
people in the hospital,
local community workers,
engineers, ecologists,
musicians, artists.
It's an absolute privilege
to work with all of these.
And with this, I just wanna say,
thank you all for listening.
- Thank you so much, Diego,
for that absolute;y
fantastic mind-blowing talk.
And thank you, Matthew, for
helping with the formulation
and the sonification of
these natural sounds.
We are, I'm just so proud
that the Franke Program
helped you get a start on
this absolutely wonderful
really ambitious project,
and we wish you the best.
And so here's, you know, let's all clap
and give you a round of applause.
We so wish we could've done
this in person as well.
But Ty, did you wanna take
over and handle the questions?
I think we have a couple coming.
- Absolutely, so just a
reminder to the audience
to please submit your questions,
not in the chat feature, but in the Q&A,
and we have one already.
So Diego, "Thank you for a
fascinating presentation.
I'm compelled by your statement that music
can be as powerful a
narrative tool as maps
for telling the story of ecological change
over space and time.
Could you speak more to
the storytelling potential
of sonifying rather than only
visualizing ecological data?"
- Sure, I'm gonna answer quickly,
and probably Matthew has a lot of wisdom
to share in there, too.
- Yes, please do, Matthew.
- The interesting part between, say,
a video of an animation of
a map, or as we have seen,
imagine the spraying, slowing
the curve of COVID in 2D
is that with data certification,
we can generate emotions.
We can say, or we can almost
anticipate what's next.
If we find certain patterns in our ears,
we can say, "Okay, we're going up.
That must mean maybe that the
bird is going up a thermal
or I have a heads-up that
is going to go down."
So the interpretation of music allows us
to disentangle my subjective view,
much more complex patterns
in a very interesting way.
- Yeah, so the interesting
thing about sound in general
is that you can hear something once
and then not hear it again
for quite a number of years,
decades even, hear it again,
and you're back in the same place
and time that you were before.
So we have a remarkable
memory for tone color.
So there's that, where our
visual memories are unreliable.
And I once had a fascinating conversation
with a detective in New York
is that if someone describes
a crime entirely in visual terms,
there's something wrong with their story.
If they do not mention smell or sound,
something serious is missing.
So it's an interesting thing.
The other thing about
sound that is remarkable
is that you can layer sound.
You can have multiple layers together,
and it will make sense.
I mean, that's literally
the meaning of harmony.
So there, I think in terms of sonification
and sort of representing
multiple layers of data,
then there's tremendous potential there.
So the way that our
brains work, for example,
is if you hear, if you
have multiple people
speaking at the same time,
we have difficulty parsing language,
but if you have multiple instrumentalists
playing at the same
time, well, we love that.
So there's, you know,
there's tremendous potential.
And I think bringing the two together
is how does and
sonification work together.
And another thing that I didn't mention,
when I work with the raw data, you know,
whether it's playing
around with the termites,
and I've worked with Marcelo Dietrich
at the School of Medicine here,
he's a neuroscientist
in comparative medicine,
looking at, there's a little
distressing crying baby mice,
and then mapping that
onto musical parameters.
There's something authentic about the data
because it's producing sounds and shapes
that I would not have done
on my own as a composer.
So I'm hearing things anew,
and I think people possibly recognize
that even that sort of
initial experimentation
with the pigeons,
there's something really,
something's going on there.
And I think that's what
we're trying to get at.
It's like, and can you
actually tell the difference
between these species, whether,
and in terms of what we are doing,
it's just, we're making decisions
in terms of what we're,
the sounds we're using,
but we're not choosing
the notes or the rhythms.
And so I think there's
a really interesting
experiment to be done there.
But I think the most important thing
is our memory of placing
sounds in time and place.
And if you're looking at
the loss of the sound world,
and this is the work of Bernie Krause,
and he's been doing these recordings
for years and years and years,
and when you layer them up
over decades, it's remarkable.
I mean, of course it's deeply distressing.
So I think this is one
way to kind of get at that
and making it clear to the public.
So that's a wonderful
question. Thank you, Megan.
- Thank you, okay, from
our next participant,
another commendation, "Wonderful work."
"A question about tracking insects,
especially regarding the
ants and termite work,
how would you track insects
in their natural environment
as opposed to Petri dishes?"
I was wondering the same thing,
and the participant, I
was thinking especially
about bees, different
sounds, different relation?
- Yeah, there, about the
tracking through computer vision,
there I have to give a shout-out
to my alma mater and past employer,
the Max Planck Institute
for Animal Behavior
and the newly formed Centre for the Study
of Advanced Collective work
from Iain Couzin and his group
has been pioneering computer vision
and tracking of really animals.
I would recommend reading papers.
There's a computer vision
package called Tracktor.
package called TRex
from Tristan Walter and Iain
Couzin, eLife 2018, I think.
And then there's also a
paper and a Python package
called DeepPoseKit from Blair Costelloe,
Iain Couzin, and a few other people.
So I would start by getting
a very clear background.
I'm not an insects person at all.
I work with ginormous tortoises
that move very slow and live forever.
That's why (laughs) I have
it easy in my research.
But those were places I would explore
with Centre for the Advanced
Study of Animal Collective.
They probably have a couple answers.
They're working with and building bridges
and how the collective helps shape
these structures that are bionic in time
to work with social networks of bees.
That would be a good starting point.
- Thank you, next question.
"Do animals change their behavior
from the sound they
generate using your code?
It would be cool to know whether they move
to make sounds they like or enjoy,
so working on a feedback there,
and again, cheers for an
amazing presentation."
- That's a really good question.
I'm not 100% sure I understand it.
But so there's a lot of research
looking at playback experiments
to see, for example,
how would zebra react if it hears a lion?
So that sort of research
has been done extensively,
also to look at how plastic
animal responses are.
Whether or not animals like certain music,
I am not sure.
I'm sure there's a lot
of psychological research
into whether dogs like
classical music or not.
I would have to see. That's
a really good question.
I might try it out with my
neighbor's dog. (laughs)
- Okay, "But music
software was used to map
the termite music, Logic, mainstream,
GarageBand, et cetera."
- And we used Ableton,
and in its simplest form,
the video that you see
there was GarageBand,
where we literally just dragged
almost randomly instruments
to see if it sounded
and sounded beautiful.
But most of the more complex patterns
that Matthew is using is
from a software Ableton.
- Okay, and a follow-up question
from the same participant,
"And for the termites, was
pitch mostly determined
by position of the termites?
If so, how were other parts of the music
like volume determined?"
Matthew, and you wanna interject here?
- Sorry, sorry, where's
this? Which question is this?
- Sorry, Aaron's question here,
"Was pitch mostly determined
by position of the termites?
And if so, how were
other parts of the music
like volume determined?"
- Yeah, so I think in
the case of the termites,
it was mostly coordinate position.
And some of the way in
which the music software
interacts with that is also
producing nuance, which is,
you know, accents and dynamic variation.
So that's not, in that case,
that's not really coming directly
from the termites.
I mean, it could, 'cause
we have enough data
to map that onto it.
- And in one of the videos
though, the one where you see
the Petri dish and the
musical instruments there,
shout-out to Jon Koss,
who's electric engineer
helping with this project.
We actually were able to
map chord progressions
based on the collective
state of the system.
So if at a given time point,
say our Excel sheet says,
"These eight termites
are in polarized state,"
it would play different chords.
Then if 20 rows later, all the termites
are like far away from each other,
that would be a transition state.
So we are actually able
to, as Matthew said,
the pitch is determined by the position,
but also some of the chords are determined
by the collective state of the system,
which is really interesting
because we're playing with
the group and the individual,
so you could almost think in future work,
someone making the background
noise and a single pigeon
or a individual playing the melody.
- Yeah, I mean, there's a little bit
of some kind of accidental discovery.
So when the animals move
from position to position,
the velocity of that movement can produce
really interesting musical results,
which was surprising to us.
So that's not programmed in directly.
That's coming from the interaction
between the data and the musical software.
So there's a gift, you
know, happy accidents.
But we could, the next step, for example,
is to look at, say, velocity and position
to not only control pitch
but to control spectral information.
So in any musical sound,
there's going to be,
you know, harmonic content,
and that harmonic content
will change over time.
That produces a nuance and shape
and a single musical note, for example.
So that's the, I think there's something,
there's a lot of potential there
when you're looking at, say,
the murmuration of starlings
where you get these sort of darker shapes
and shading and things like that.
I mean, there's so many animals,
it wouldn't make sense to map
them all onto a single pitch,
but you could control
like the filtering of it.
So we are also getting
into psychoacoustics here.
So there's a kind of
psychological testing element
to this, which is potentially
really exciting, too.
So going back to the original question,
like what does sonification offer?
And it's also, it does have this side
of psychological dimension too, which is,
you know, I think it
has a lot of potential.
- Indeed, okay, we have many questions.
It's a measure of how
engaged the audience is
with your wonderful presentation.
Beth asks, "What, if any,
impact do the sounds made
by the animals have when
sonifying their movement?
Do you ever integrate their natural sounds
with the instrumental sounds,
and if so, is it harmonic?"
- (laughs) We have started
to experiment with that,
and so we have these wonderful,
I had an AudioMoth in my backyard
just sitting there for a month,
and yes, it records every 20 minutes,
and we have like
absolutely enormous amounts
of these recordings, and I
mean, it really does work
just to play the recording using, say,
the Merlin app from the
Cornell Ornithology Lab,
and it will identify it.
So the idea is to create
ambient backgrounds
that are essentially filtered,
you know, filtering out I-95,
which is also not too
far away from my house.
And you can create rather wonderful
shifting musical textures,
and the idea is that we would put those
behind the more frenetic tracking data.
So I'm really glad that
someone had that observation.
That's a, yeah, it's good thought.
- Yeah, as Matthew said,
that's a great point.
And yeah, I'm working on a
song called "Glitch Crab"
where I wanna map some melodies
made by craps using computer vision,
but also the sound they
make when they close their,
whatever this is called, so stay tuned.
It will come to my SoundCloud. (laughs)
- Yeah, and please share
it with us. We'll post it.
Okay, an evocative question from Steven,
"Some giant tortoises still alive today
were also alive when Beethoven went deaf.
How do we tell the story
of a 200-year-old life through music?
Can we bring the living tortoise
and dead Beethoven together?"
- I think Matthew might
answer this question
as he has been working on an
opera with people who were.
- Oh, yes, so I'm working on
an opera about Alan Turing,
and we've trained it, the
libretto was written by an AI.
We're using GPT-2 and
GPT-3, and we've trained it
only on Turing's published papers
and also books that we knew
that he had read as a child.
And then you ask the AI,
"Can computers think? Can machines think?"
And you get these rather
extraordinary answers.
So I think there's possibly potential
to use artificial intelligence
for predictive sound-making,
and we have done some
experiments with that.
You can use this, these same algorithms
can be used for images as well.
So it's not, GPT-2 or GPT-3
are a natural language model.
So primarily they're there
for language construction,
but you can use them for
sound and image as well.
So yeah, so that's kind of a
Holy Grail, but sure. (laughs)
- Something to aspire to.
- Yeah.
- From Richard,
"What about tracking radiant
shifts in internal parameters,
such as temperature, electrical
activity, et cetera?"
- That's a great idea,
and one of my PhD chapters
is actually to see whether
animals can predict weather.
And I think anyone who
has seen bird flying
knows where thermals are, so
that's a really good idea.
We have increasingly a good ability
to track the physiology
of animals in the wild.
And we have mechanistic
models that are based
on energy expenditure of
animals that allow us to,
we could build on these theories
and create these principles,
just how we have created the principles
of collective behavior and
translate those to physiology.
I'm kinda improvising here,
but if a mice eats something,
you could look at its heart rate,
or you could look at its caloric intake
and play around with that,
and maybe the sound of cake
eaten by a mice sounds
different than a carrot.
I don't know. (laughs)
- That was Richard Prum's
suggestion, actually,
when he came to visit, when
he visited the exhibition
and the performance at Tsai CITY,
and he thought that that
would be a way of tracking,
say, certainly like starlings and things
and these sort of mass demonstrations
that you see in nature, so
that's a great suggestion.
- Great, one more question
before we wrap up.
Let's see, it says, the participant asks,
"I was wondering if you have
thought about how to interact
with Indigenous non-scientific,
non-Western interpretations
of animal movements and sounds?
Indigenous groups throughout the world
have local alternative ways
of interpreting animal
sounds and movements.
For example, the songs of certain birds
mean certain things for
particular Indigenous groups,
and certain communities have a history
of imitating and
incorporating animal sounds
into their own musical practices
and movement practices.
So how have these modes of
listening and mapping sound,
how could they be put in conversation
with your own projects?"
Very insightful question.
- Oh, I love that question.
Thank you so much for bringing that up.
And as someone who's
from the Global South,
this is incredibly
important to me personally
on every single level,
including my science.
And as an example, the
country I'm from, Uruguay,
actually means river of the painted birds.
Gua means coming off, y means water,
and uru could mean zone
of or a type of bird.
So everything in our
language, our reality,
names of places have a
variety of different meaning
depending on different culture,
different spiritual practices.
So I'm incredibly excited of
when I go to home this year
in South America and
travel a little bit more,
it's been hard with the COVID-19 pandemic,
to learn more and listen
how different animals
have been perceived through culture,
especially as we start thinking about,
for example, United
States Land Back movements
and how this relates to the
cultural heritage of people.
This is a great question.
- No, it's so fantastic question.
So I composed an opera
a number of years ago
about the meeting of the Europeans
with Maori in New Zealand,
so when Captain Cook first came,
and I collaborated with a Maori musician
who was playing a variety of instruments,
and she was a trained musician,
but it wasn't a useful conversation
to sort of approach it
from a Western perspective.
So the most valuable thing to do
is to talk about the story
and the place and the material
and the purpose of the
instruments that she was using.
And then through that essentially
kind of dramaturgical conversation,
we were able to find a
place for that in the music.
So I think that the most
important step, of course,
is the nature of the conversation
and figuring out how to communicate.
So it's a wonderful
question, and, you know,
I would absolutely want
to investigate that.
And the Maori name for
New Zealand, Aotearoa,
means land of the long white cloud,
so we can talk about origin
names (laughs), yeah.
- Anyway, let me take this moment
to once again thank you
both, Diego and Matthew,
for an absolutely wonderful journey.
What an exciting, inspiring project.
And I think that the prospect
of conveying the urgency
of climate change, the
loss in biodiversity,
if sonification can
emotionally compel people
to believing it and
springing into action, gosh,
we would be living in
a very different world.
So collectively with sort of, I mean,
this was absolutely thrilling.
We wish you very well.
Please keep us posted with the work.
And thank you so much, Ty,
for helping set up the event
and to Guy for recording
and making this all happen.
And Ty, also, thanks for handling
these wonderful questions.
Thanks to the audience
for engaging so deeply
and asking such meaningful questions.
So before I draw the event to a close,
I just want to mention that we have
one other Franke Fellow
to close out this season
this year, this academic year.
Dr. Ana Florence, a former
a Franke Fellow as well,
who has moved, has gotten a
faculty position at Columbia.
And she'll be talking to us
about "Social and Structural Contours
of Marginalization in
the Context of COVID-19,"
talking about her work
with marginalized groups.
So once again, thank you
very much, and bye, everyone.
And Matthew and Diego, this project
is just absolutely thrilling.
I hope you get a chance to share it
with many, many more people.
We'd be happy to advertise what
you're doing on our website.
And Matthew, please do invite us
to your opera when it's done.
- Oh, sure. (laughs)
- Yeah, and I think what is
very exciting for me as well
was a recent Nobel Prize in
physics went to Giorgio Parisi,
who actually worked out
the collective phenomena,
the description, the language to describe
the motion of starlings, for example,
which is the same kind of
formalism that you would have
to describe the collective
behavior of atoms.
So it's the same underlying
framework that transcends.
So your work is inspiring very similarly
with the kinds of applications, thank you.